from a twisted mass of rotted and broken
timbers to a living functioning an
impressive example of a medieval
whorehouse this is a story of
reconstruction and restoration that
saved one of the earliest examples of
timber-framed presented in essex from
the demolition member providing a
glimpse into the past four generations
of the future it is also a detective
story but one without a crime unless the
passage of time and the ravages of
insects and weather can be so called
number 17 South Street Rochford is the
prosaic modern address of this charming
building now in use as watchword council
offices but it was not always sir in
years past it was known to some as the
Moot house because people believed it
had been used for public meetings it was
also called the pink house because of
the color of its walls that
distinguished it from other houses in
South Street these days however it is
referred to quite simply as the old
house a name which accurately reflects
both its early origins and the friendly
familiarity in which it has become to be
held for years the old house had been
sinking into neglect not by any willful
Act but rather through the inability of
its owners to cope with the strain of
maintaining a 10 roomed building that
had long ago seen its best days
then in June 1982 Rochford Council
bought it with the intention of
preserving what was then officially
recognized as a 15th century building
AHA stating from the time of the
Plantagenet kings clearly a great deal
of work needed to be done and the old
house was soon enveloped in plastic
sheeting to protect it from the elements
while work proceeded and it was beneath
that plastic shroud that skilled
detective work would prise open and
reveal the old houses amazing secrets
outwardly the old house is typical of
many in East Anglia with its central
main hall joined by two cross rings in a
u-shape but as layer after layer was
peeled away suspicions grew that the
origins of the building were much
earlier than had been supposed sulfuric
consultant to Essex County Council and
the National authority on medieval
chamber famed buildings saw from the
newly exposed joints that the main hall
had been built in the late 13th century
carpenters marks in Roman numerals
attested to the extensive additions that
came later and reinforced mr. Hewett in
his belief that here was a remarkably
early building much further than the
15th century dating by which it was
officially listed his view was to be
confirmed later by radiocarbon tests on
small samples of oak joists from the
main hall dating the building at about
twelve seventy but further evidence was
to be found Essex County archaeologists
conducted extensive digs concentrating
largely on suspected drainage systems
among many unexpected finds they came up
with a silver penny from the reign of
Henry the third whose rich ran in the
land from 1216 to 1272
with the workmen busy around them the
archaeologists continued their
investigations and unearthed pieces of
cutlery and pottery a medieval ring and
some shells and bones as well as a
lady's shoe
this latter was probably placed with the
silver penny as a good luck talisman
during the original building work but
conclusive proof of the old houses
ancient origins was the discovery of an
open hearth lined with tiles and
surrounded by an oaken curb in the
middle of the main hall this was later
to be restored to its original state and
preserved for display the interest of
Essex County Council archeology section
in this project is to try to elucidate
the building sequence here and also to
see if there are any previous buildings
underneath it we've done other work in
Rockford itself and this will go to help
us build up a pattern of medieval life
in the town from such evidence
historians were indeed able to
reconstruct a picture of life in the
hall with the entire family living
cooking eating and sleeping as well as
often keeping no cattle for neutral work
in the same square chamber open to the
world the harm heaped with logs provided
the main source of warmth light and
cooking facilities with the smoke
drifting upwards to escape through open
louvers in the thatched roof top
the master a man of considerable
substance and his family would probably
have taken their meals at a table on a
raised platform across the north wall
the servants would have eaten at tables
running down the length of the straw
carpet at all and slept on them at night
more radiocarbon tests showed that it
was some twenty or thirty years before
the family could enjoy a little more
privacy in the newly constructed north
wing it was another hundred years before
the servants were provided with a proper
workplace and quarters
with the addition of the south wing in
the case of each wing the only means of
access to the upper floor was by ladder
for the mysterious and still unknown
inhabitants of the old house little
seemed to have changed for the next 400
years in the tiny Market Village at the
lowest Ford over the river Roche life
followed the slow eaters of nature while
in the default vaulted Asian core the
wall of the laser's restful and Henry
the eighth dissolved the monasteries
including the nearby piccolo Priory and
Shakespeare established himself as
England's greatest playwright
but suddenly in South Central
there was a great change in building
styles the old house was caught up in
the great race to modernize among many
other changes an upper floor was
constructed in the main hall with a
dormer window to light it and it was the
addition of this upper floor which
concealed for centuries the fact that
there had indeed been architectural
stirrings at the old house during the
four hundred years sleep as workmen in
the 1980s stripped away the renovations
from down the ages they revealed perhaps
the old houses greatest secret
the Magnificent 16th century chimney in
the main hall that is one of the
buildings greatest attractions today
it's size and the delicate brickwork
typical of the early 15th century are
testimony to the prestige and wealth of
the owner of the old house at that time
only a few chimneys of such elegant
design have been discovered in Essex and
this with its try foiled arches and
diapered patterns is widely regarded as
among the best of them another
remarkable discovery during the 20th
century restoration was the smoke
blackened Timbers in the roof above the
original half evidence of the original
smoke venting system these have been
left untreated
but protected from decay or insect
attacked by the heavy suit incrustation
the 17th century burst a building added
a chimney stack of less impressive but
still cherishable design in the north
wing as well as staircases to the upper
floors and an extension behind the main
hall this work extending into the 18th
century marks the heyday of the old
house as a home for a family of some
prestige from then on the building
slipped gradually into a long slow
decline which continued until Rochford
council decided to restore it
the old house was being used as a
Chandler's shop by George Garrett in the
18th century when asked where Georgian
Bay was added to the front of the north
wing in the early 19th century George
Turner a cobbler rented the old house as
premises from Thomas Hearst Marsh who
also owned the neighboring red house
during the last half of that century
John Hitchcock another cobbler could be
seen making boots and shoes in one
window while his wife Emma an
accomplished NIDA woman sat in the other
running their fancy goods business the
old house passed through several hands
subsequently being used as a family home
by among others a solicitor and a
retired minister when Rochford counsel
acquired it for 45,000 pounds in January
1982 many believe the old house had long
past any kind of useful life certainly
it had proved too much of a burden for
successive owners from the very
beginning it was clear that such a
priceless example of early medieval
craftsmanship should not be brought back
from the grave only to serve as a museum
piece it was built for a useful life and
having survived 700 years it needed the
continuing sustenance of life and action
the decision was made even before
Rochford council completed its purchase
of the old house it would house the
chief executive suite
providing office accommodation for him
and 12 members of his staff for the
councillors team of architects it was a
daunting task from the roof to the
floors this building which would have to
meet exacting modern specifications for
office use was on the verge of collapse
the north wing fell in during early
investigations the most urgent job
therefore was to install internal
scaffolding to prop it up work on the
site began in earnest six months after
the purchase with teams of men hired to
help clear out 20 skip loads of modern
building materials used by the previous
owner as well as various items of
furniture at the same time the project
architect was busy drawing up endless
sections elevations and floor plans to
locate every structural detail the
preparatory work continued until the end
of December to be followed immediately
by erection of the outer cocoon of steel
and plastic to prevent any further
deterioration as work progressed
this was a wise decision for despite the
fact that the old house was ahead of its
time in being built on stone foundations
it was leaning to the rear and had to be
jacked up by as much as 18 inches room
by room
it meant stripping the frame of all its
cladding in the process some find
examples of wattle and daub panels were
uncovered these were carefully protected
and - showing the mud dung and reeds and
rushes gathered from the nearby river
Roach had been preserved for display
under glass panels in the main hall
where they were found the stripping of
the walls also uncovered the remnants of
rare and imposing triple bracing in the
front wall on either side of the main
support post to the hall such multiple
bracing is typical of the short
decorated period of Gothic architecture
and must have looked very imposing
unfortunately they were too badly
decayed to be left exposed to view in
tackling this huge project both the
council architects and the main
contractors Haynes and Smith a South End
were united in one thought as much as
possible of the original structure
should be retained and any replacement
Timbers crafted in the traditional
manner but this presented a huge problem
Deathwatch beetle furniture beetle and
dry and damp rot had caused extensive
damage over the centuries some beams and
joists had been eaten away from their
original square cross-section into block
shapes by the beetle in some cases to
remove timbers crumbled beyond repair
would have meant to weaken linked
structures and perhaps ruin them
fortunately modern techniques could be
brought to the rescue of the ancient
records timber treatment limited
specialists in renovation of damaged
wood were brought in at a cost of fifty
thousand pounds to mastermind this
aspect of the restoration one of the
most dramatic and effective techniques
employed was the use of epoxy resin
which can be used to strengthen replace
and even imitate wood this massive Thai
beam in the front room of the north wing
had been seriously weakened and then
broken by the removal of supporting
Timbers for some unknown reason more
than a hundred years ago it balanced
precariously on a small brace and was
crudely lashed along its length to a
piece of old railway line
it was first temporarily repaired and
then using a technique similar to this
carpenters carefully removed a section
along its top edge and inserted a carbon
fiber rod then epoxy resin was poured in
around it filling the void and giving
the new man-made beam even more strength
and resilience than the original work
while at the same time leaving its
outward appearance unchanged similar
techniques were used all over the old
house weakened beams were boxed in with
plywood and epoxy resin poured in to
give renewed strength after sanding and
staining they were indistinguishable
from the original replacement of minor
members such as these stud fixings
brought into play epoxy bonded dowel
joints to replace the traditional
mortise and Tenon's new sections of
posts and beams were spliced in with
seat cuts spliced joints or traditional
scarf joints gentle sandblasting cleaned
and brightened all the framework without
damaging the original tool markings and
timber preservative was applied to guard
against further infestation and rot an
exciting discovery during the work was
the location of diamond-shaped window
mullions destroyed long ago and new
timbers were inserted to recall the
original effect
these windows would have been unglazed
and covered by wooden shutters at night
rotted insect eaten and broken rafters
were built up with the aid of softwood
top plates giving renewed strength and
straightening the new roofline thin flat
steel bracing gave the roof a lateral
stability that was lacking in the
original construction the old joints of
repaired rafters came back together
neatly allowing the new oak pegs to
slide sweetly into the original dowel
holes wherever possible in the
restoration spare wood from
reconstruction was cleaned up and used
in other parts of the house but much of
the timber brought in was in fact far
from new a source of well seasoned oak
was found in the demolition of an
overhead country a John SADS old timber
wharf at Molden just a few miles up the
Essex cursed this was fashioned and cut
to size by barons of West Cliff who wore
out many a slow blade on the iron like
timber despite the necessary
introduction of modern methods the
decision to use traditional materials
and techniques as far as possible was
rigorously applied even to the reclad
enough the walls modern fiberglass quilt
insulation vapor barriers and breather
papers were allied to old methods with
larvan plaster to create an effective
but traditionally based skin for the old
house one inch by half inch lads secured
at half inch intervals to the stubs were
coated in traditional lime hair plaster
and instead of using a modern external
emulsion the old values of lime wash
were revived it was made on-site to the
age-old formula with lime putty and
tallow heated and blended in a large
tank the distemper for the inside walls
set off a nationwide search for a
manufacturer of this long ignored
coating the last remaining maker was
tracked down in the Irish Republic
when the old house was first built it
had a fetched roof this was later
replaced by burnt clay tiles many had
survived the stripping down and were
reused as the roof was made
weather-tight
above its modern insulation one of the
last stages in the long process of
restoration was the replacement of the
floors one room alone needed little
extra work
the upstairs back room of the north wing
had its original oak floor board still
in good condition and secured with wide
blacksmith's nails
apart from cleaning it needed little
restoration testimony to the quality of
work put into the Masters bedroom
elsewhere wooden floors were covered
with plywood and strengthened to conform
with modern office use specifications
ground floors were concreted over damped
roof membranes and paved with brick the
biggest headache of all was the
provision of all the services needed to
run a modern office heating water power
computer cables telephone links and
security systems all had to be concealed
or at least disguised to maintain the
atmosphere of antiquity inside and out
this was achieved to a remarkable degree
aided by careful and discreet choices of
furniture carpets and curtains which
balanced modern efficiency with a
lasting impression of age in keeping
with the spirit of the whole project
even the fine oak refectory table and
matching chairs in the main hall were
made from wood leftover from repairs to
the timber frame in all the restoration
of the old house to its early splendor
took 10 months and cost 235 thousand
pounds was it all worth it certainly it
was if only as an example of how our
towns early history can be thrown into
sharp relief for future generations by
dedicated and conscientious attention to
minut detail
the old house has now been designated a
grade-two starred listed building an
award previously withheld because the
house was in such a poor state of repair
there was no doubt either in the minds
of the town's folk who crowded into the
old house at its official opening by
Councillor miss Beryl Lovett chairman of
the Council on the 8th of December 1983
and a lot of you here have children and
their children and their children's
children will be able to come and look
at this house and they'll learn from the
house itself the history of the place in
which they live and I think that's
really very splendid I think we are very
fortunate to have such a place in our
area and I must say it looks beautiful
beyond all my wildest dreams and I want
to say how very proud I am to be part of
a council that got on with it and made
sure that it stayed here rather than let
let it just fall to the ground because
that's what would have happened
I'm finding it is little strange that
I'm supposed to open 17 South Street I
think that she never closed and she just
had a little rest with pleasure I pull
this cord and I reopen centium South
Street and god bless all who work in her
in the run-up to Christmas more than
3,000 people came to admire the amazing
transformation from ruin to pride and
still they come the young and the not
sir young on frequent guided tours while
the essential work of the council goes
on around them against all the odds the
700 year old house is alive again and
ready for another 700 years
but knit the last words be with
counseling miss lammott and the chief
executive of the cook at that memorable
opening ceremony the house ladies and
gentlemen is yours for only don't take
it away and I'm sure they never will